we also through the search warrant  effort we recovered a pair of shoes as  you'll see here on my screen here to the  left that match the suspect's  description  um also as you can see there's apparent  blood on the shoes and the shoes were  cut likely in a manner to try to destroy  evidence  in addition to the shoes we recovered a  straw hat that was also cut in a manner  that was likely to destroy the evidence  and that straw hat as you can see  matches the one in the photo  just something to point out that black  brim is actually the interior part of  the hat a sweat band not the exterior  part but we analyzed the hat analyze the  shoes and then ultimately one of the  most important aspects of this  investigation was waiting on the dna  results and we received positive dna  results that showed  robert tell us his dna at the crime  scene